this morning Israel's prime minister
urged European allies to support the
president's decision that follows a
series of violent protests by
Palestinians over the weekend four
people were killed and dozens hurt Seth
Doane is in Jerusalem where there are
fears the violence will continue south
good morning good morning Hamas the
Islamic group has issued ominous new
warnings about more violence to come and
new fronts have opened in this battle
beyond Israel demonstrations continued
around the world today this one in
Bangladesh in Israel police
reinforcements were deployed this
morning following the stabbing of an
Israeli security guard at a Jerusalem
bus station and street protests the
debate has been crude and while
diplomats may not be throwing stones the
divisions over president Trump's
recognition of Jerusalem are just as
clear in Brussels today Israeli Prime
Minister Benjamin Netanyahu urged
European leaders to give a yet to be
seen us peace plan a chance
truce alone has been the capital of
Israel for the last 70 years I think
what President Trump has done is put
facts squarely on the table Arab League
foreign ministers over the weekend
announced mr. Trump's decision saying it
pushed the region from the violence what
do you think about President Trump's
decision well he made the right decision
the question is was the timing and the
circumstances Wright's veteran Israeli
diplomat Alam Pincus was chief of staff
to four foreign ministers he worries mr.
Trump's move could make this region even
more volatile the president and some of
his advisors have been talking at length
about the deal of the century and the
peace process to end all peace processes
I haven't seen that it's like the Loch
Ness peace process and now we have
official confirmation from the White
House that the Palestinians have pulled
out of a meeting scheduled between vice
president Mike Pence and Mahmoud Abbas
the Palestinian president that meeting
is officially cancelled Nora
set stone in Jerusalem thank you